restaurants hotels and other businesses
that survived the pandemic
now face a new crisis not enough workers
across the country businesses are
struggling to fill many positions
just as large numbers of americans get
vaccinated
and look forward to vacations our lead
national correspondent david bagno is in
long beach new york david good morning
good morning to you look with the end of
the pandemic insight we're all ready to
travel right
and as you get ready to travel you're
going to find that some bars restaurants
and hotels are
having a hard time finding workers a lot
of people left and they need them to
come back to work
a good example of that is cape cod
massachusetts
that's where we're going to take you to
this morning
welcome to the beautiful cape cod the
iconic seaside
tourist destination that roughly 2
million people visit
every summer tourists are not the only
summer visitors though
businesses typically hire between 15 and
20 000
extra workers to keep up with the summer
demand
but this year finding enough staff is
becoming a real problem
we're going to be more efficient david
columbo has three restaurants
one that boasts the best lobster roll in
new england
pretty good what are you applying for
columbo says he needs to find about 40
more workers
so you're just waiting for 40 people to
walk through the door it's funny this
year you have to entice them a little
more
you know they know the situation well
you're giving more money and so and so
forth but that's interesting
yeah yeah you know they a little bit
more demand they have a little bit of
the upper hand right now
and uh you know it's better than having
nobody
you know what are you willing to pay a
little bit more uh well that's you know
i wish not to say that because they may
be listening
there are several barriers causing the
worker shortage says cape cod chamber of
commerce ceo
wendy northcross people stay home they
crunch the numbers and they see what
their unemployment benefits are versus
what their potential exposure
is versus their child care needs and
they're making decisions to just kind of
sit out another summer
you know similar hurdles are threatening
other beach towns tourism is a nearly
seven billion dollar business
in cape may county which is in new
jersey chamber of commerce president
vicki clark says a backlog of temporary
j-1 student visas are adding to the
problem
that program did not happen last year
because of covid
and uh there is a huge backlog of these
applications this year
not all embassies around the world have
opened up and so
students are having a very difficult
time getting their visa appointments
so tell me how many employees do you
need
we blossomed to 675 employees during
high season
so we need to bring about 400 employees
back on cape cod in massachusetts
gary thulander runs the chatham bars inn
and he's dealing with the same problem
roughly 125 of his employees
need to get a temporary work visa in
order to work for him
and when we met him he had some good
news to share the consulates just opened
up in the eastern bloc countries and
also jamaica and dominican republic
that's going to help us dramatically
filling out our needs so for staffing
levels coming up
this big news for you it's huge news for
us absolutely
you know it really comes down to
unemployment benefits and temporary work
visas but there's also a temporary
housing issue anthony we were told that
on cape cod a lot of people moved out of
the big city say boston for example
moved to cape cod to work from home
during the pandemic
and now some of these temporary workers
are saying hey i'll go back to cape cod
to work but
i'm having a hard time finding a place
to live while i'm there
yeah a lot of people moved around in the
pandemic david david doing a bit of a
short tour there thank you david
that's right and some nice eating on
cape cod yeah that lobster roll looks
good tastes
really good yeah but guys if the if the
unemployment benefits
uh you get more staying home than if you
get a job well
what is the incentive to go get it well
that's that's always that was
the complaint to some degree about the
the stimulus package was that people
getting these checks were going to be
less for
but i don't buy that if you got it no
because if you see that there's a job
opening you want to you want to get in a
job before somebody else takes it
the housing is a is a bigger issue
because when you don't have
uh many things open the prices go
through the roof and no one can pay you
enough to cover that right and the visa
issue which is because a lot of these
a lot of these resort communities rely
on foreign workers they do in the summer
particularly